and as long as we have the blue dust
we'll never run out of flying dust
sometimes they're mcu superheroes and
other days they're giving voice to
amazing animated characters
today we're taking a look at the varied
animated characters in some of our
favorite movies and tv shows that are
performed by marvel actors
which performer wrote to the production
team asking to be part of their show
which grinch line was improvised by
benedict cumberbatch
what in the world is happening the film
onward has not one but two marvel stars
lending their voices to bring this pair
of brothers to life
who are you we're the avengers man
during press for the movie chris pratt
said that it was one of the most
emotional films he'd ever experienced
working on in his career
in part because of his personal
connection to the material
no i have three remember his beard was
scratchy had a goofy laugh and he used
to play drums on his feet
pratt said that the brotherly
relationship he portrays with holland
feels similar to his relationship with
his actual brother
for holland it was a pretty special
experience as well
tapping into any brain just let me go
explaining that
this film has made me love my dad even
more
after watching this wonderful film we'll
call their loved ones and tell them how
much they love them and appreciate them
ryan reynolds was fascinated when he
first saw the fully rendered version of
pikachu because of just how skilled the
work of the animators was
it was a bit of a shock to see just how
real the pikachu felt and how well the
character suited the voice
and of course vice versa harry faked his
own
death or somebody else faked harry's
death
one of the reasons reynolds was excited
about being part of pokemon detective
pikachu
was because it's a movie he knew he
could share with his children since it
was slated to be such a family film
i was excited to do a film that my kids
would love for me that's a big one
it makes sense since so many of his past
projects definitely
weren't what he'd want to show to his
young kids at the time a while before
she took to the screen as black widow
johansson spent some time with spongebob
squarepants
the actress was just 19 years old at the
time johansen was the voice of princess
mindy
here take this a mermaid living
underwater who whips out some mermaid
magic to support patrick and spongebob
in the spongebob squarepants movie
spongebob wherever you are you better
hurry filming spies in disguise was
quite the feat for the spider-man actor
super nerd which is me
i always seem to play the nerd has to um
kind of step
up and help him save the day his role as
scientist walter beckett was the very
first full-length film he did voiceover
for
a hydrothermal explosion is about to
melt your face off
while holland had loads of interactions
with his co-star in the movie
he didn't actually meet will smith in
person in the entire
two and a half years they were making
the film pretend like you're a normal
person
talking to a much cooler normal person
the actors were based in different
cities while recording
holland in new york and smith in los
angeles
it was only during press that they
actually got to meet the marvel actor
pair got a chance to put their spy
skills to work when they did an escape
room together
spies in disguise tom holland will smith
is
like it's very very funny scarlett
johansson didn't just do voice over
early on in her career
she's been a brilliant addition to
multiple projects including
the live-action mowgli yes
would you like to see it was a really
exciting experience for johansson who
got to reinvent the character for this
version of the story since she played
car as a seductive female storyteller
whereas in the cartoon kaw is a boy and
more of a goofy pal to mowgli
the way khan moves in the animation
affected her vocal performance and vice
versa
don't you know what you are i know what
you are
when chris pratt heard about the lego
movie two years before it was even made
the actor was extremely excited by what
sounded like a film that would speak to
adults and children alike in a creative
way
i just was blown away at the
inventiveness the creativity
for the second lego movie he took on the
role of rex dangervest and was able to
bring a different vocal quality to the
screen
emmett was perkier and higher pitch wow
my own rex vest
well he got to go with a rougher sound
for dangerous voice
trust me it's ruled by an alien queen
and she'll try to brainwash your friends
andy circus was extremely impressed
while he was directing dr
strange actor benedict cumberbatch in
the mowgli film for one
he gave a very physical performance and
was actually wearing a head-mounted
camera to capture his movements for the
film
part of what made this role a stand out
for the actor was how cumberbatch
brought out the layers of personality
and shared a character who while he was
a villain was also complex in his own
right
you do not want to challenge me the
animated film the pirate fairy
saw none other than loki of the mcu as
captain james hook
exactly we needed a captain
hiddleston not only shares his speaking
voice in the film but his singing as
well
when asked about the experience
hiddleston said he had the time of his
life
part of the reason he loves voice work
so much is because of the challenge of
telling a story and
only having his voice to express himself
look at that man having so much fun
being him doctor strange played another
legendary character
the grinch benedict cumberbatch would
get really into the character's
physicality while in the recording booth
to the point that he actually had to be
cautious not to ruin the quality of the
voice recording
you will not see me later and i will not
be celebrating
cumberbatch had a lot of fun and even
improvised while he was in the booth
the line yeah yeah have a nice life it
was made up on the spot while recording
and since it suited the role and film
it managed to be included tessa thompson
aka valkyrie
had a strong connection to the
live-action film lady and the [ __ ]
i think you can be on your way now
thanks for your
help in a press interview she said it
was one of the greatest love stories
ever told the classic spaghetti kiss
scene was actually the first time that
she thought about romance when she was
young
the actress has another personal
connection to the role as well
she is the proud owner of a rescue pup
the actress credited her dog counterpart
as an excellent performer and expressed
the joy that came with giving a voice to
a real animal she got to interact with
look i
have been on the street maybe for not as
long as you but i
have done it when we think of black
widow we don't usually think of music
but scarlett johansson actually had a
fairly solid music career in the 2000s
releasing multiple albums and eps as
well as being part of a girl group
the actors got to show off her voice
when she played ash and sang
set it all free in the film sing when
asked about working on recording the
film johansen said the experience
was so fun and free who can ask for
anything better than that
uh you guys okay
did frozone's voice sound familiar to
you hey that isn't going to hold them
long
samuel l jackson did the voice for the
animated character in both the
incredibles and the incredibles 2.
that is freaky when it came to making
the second film
jackson said it was a relief because so
many fans have been inquiring after the
first one came out
iron man himself made a cameo and family
guy only
not as the avenger but instead as lois's
long-lost brother who was once locked
away in an insane asylum
he's feeding he killed twice and he's
gonna do it again
robert downey jr was the one who made
the first move since he was a big fan of
the show
and had wanted to be part of it for
quite a while he has to be part of the
show somehow and when the time was right
the marvel actor made one guest
appearance as patrick pewterschmidt
the ant-man actor was the very first
person who brought to life the fiance to
susan
derrick dietl in monsters vs aliens no
susan you're like
really glowing you're green when the tv
series
short came around actor nolan north took
over the role
for both the first and second lego
movies none other than the mcu's maria
hill
aka kobe smalders was the voice of lego
wonder woman
he's off having a separate standalone
adventure the actress said it was really
fun because she felt like she was part
of a mini avengers
in the lego world taking a look behind
the mic reminds us
just how talented so many of our
favorite marvel actors are
who knew tom holland and will smith
could develop such strong chemistry
while recording on opposite sides of the
country
which of these animated characters
voiced by an mcu performer surprised you
most